[Music]
seven reasons why you will love
hypocracy you guys gonna love this
episode we're gonna get a little crazy
I'm gonna do something I've never done
before I'm going to encourage you to
make wild custom personalized typeface
stick around
[Music]
we're gonna get into how to make your
own custom fonts this episode is
sponsored by fot self the question you
might be thinking to yourself right now
is does the world need another poorly
designed typeface and the answer is a
little bit more complicated because
normally I would just say outright no
I've opted they're all only recommend a
handful of typefaces for people to use
so am i doing at about-face just because
we're getting paid to do this nope
that's not it at all
so my answer is maybe Navy and I'll talk
about that now
the founders of font self these guys I
like going through this catalog in a
little bit they're on this mission and
they think typography is this untapped
self expressive form of design of
creativity so they believe that
everybody should be able to make their
own font as a form of self-expression so
they call it type aa cracy its
typography and democracy hypocracy you
guys get okay
hypocrisy well here's the thing if you
were like me you might be a little
reluctant to jump in here for a number
of good reasons I can think of three at
least and the challenges that we face in
this is really summed up here from Greg
Lindy he said that the first 90% of the
job is great and it's fun this is true
about all creative things not just
designing your own font but the fun part
is the creation and all the
possibilities it's that last 10% where
it becomes really tedious and he's a
well-respected world-renowned font
designer among other things so the image
of The Tortoise comes in where it was
fun at the beginning and now things are
starting to slow down and doesn't get
fun anymore
well that's about to change well the
three challenges that I see that are one
it's very complex
you're talking about learning new
software dealing with kerning pairs and
just tedious hours days weeks worth of
drawing utter forms just so you can see
something and use it so back in the day
there were only a handful of programs
and they seemed very intimidating hence
the reason why in start and - as
naturally things that are complex take a
lot of time to do and one of the things
that I'm doing today which takes a lot
of time but
not aware of is I have vector drawings
of letterforms and I literally copy and
paste and arrange them one at a time so
you can imagine if I'm trying to do this
at any scale it's gonna take forever
again probably one of the reasons why I
use a commercially prepared font and
number three as we've mentioned is it's
difficult and tedious it's hours and
hours staring at your screen learning
new software that you don't already know
how well all that's gonna change with
this software font self so here are five
reasons that I put together as to why
you might want to consider designing
your very own font okay here we go
number one it's prestigious
you think about world-renowned designers
the thing that seems to separate the
average designers from the upper shelf
designers is that they've been able to
create a font and we know and love and
use their fonts and we know their name
in in some instances like Helvetica or
Futura
with Paul Renner we remember their name
four decades after the creation of the
typeface itself that's pretty cool so
it's very prestigious to I've noticed
that some design and branding firms
actually release a custom version of a
typeface that they either had
commissioned or drew themselves they
could have modified a commercially
available one or just drawn one from
scratch and I'll show you some examples
in a little bit so in a way being able
to say that you designed a custom font
for your client for their exclusive use
that's pretty cool don't you think it's
free rather than cutting and pasting
either bitmap or vector graphics
together to create a usable word now you
can sit there and create a font in the
time that it might take you to arrange
one word you can create the entire font
family you can share it with your
co-workers you can share it with your
staff and you can share it with your
clients pretty awesome for guess what in
this super hyper personalized world if
you make your own font and you don't
distribute it to the world which is your
choice you alone have the exclusive use
of that typeface that you've designed
that's pretty cool in it of itself and
last but not lease
is that I'm gonna mention two people
that I know at least two who make
passive income from the fonts that
they've created and shared with the
world that's also really cool so a lot
of you guys have seen us talk about
creating a passive income business model
well if you're a designer you might sit
there and think what can I do that's a
value to the world well here's your
answer so you guys want to stick around
for the remainder of this episode
because we're gonna get into some design
theory about what you need to know just
some fundamentals and a little kind of
peeking around as I draw three typefaces
let's see how it goes okay before moving
forward let's start with the Masters of
typeface design max manager and eduard
hoffmann the designers of Helvetica the
most ubiquitous typeface in the world I
love it and if you're paying attention
you can see that I'm using it right now
so there's no news there then there's
Giambattista Bodoni which I also love as
a typeface Viktor Largent who designed
Times New Roman
Paul Renner Futura which is the namesake
of this channel I love futurus so much I
called this company the future the food
tour then there's Adrian Frutiger who
designed fruit agar and a veneer and
that's him right there holding a type
specimen book I think
and then there's cloud Garamond the
designer of Garamond well these names
you may or may not be familiar with but
if you're really into typefaces and type
design you definitely know who the
Masters are but we're here in the future
so let's talk about some present-day
superstars in no particular order
there's Greg Lindy who I mentioned
Jonathan Hoffler who you may or may not
have seen on abstract the Netflix series
Susanna lick oh and Rudy Van Allen's for
emigres Erik Spiekermann and Tobias
frere-jones here are some of the
examples of the typefaces they've
designed mrs. Eve's one of my favorite
serif typefaces is designed by Susanna
lick oh and I love it for all the little
characters that she's created a classic
typeface beautiful serif typeface and
here's some from Greg Lindy from his his
company Lux typo and look at this
typeface that he created called sudafed
sans and this was for Johnson & Johnson
comp
and it was a way of using a custom
typeface for the entire marketing and
packaging efforts to keep everything
super consistent I think that's a rad
idea and then Jonathan hofler and Tobias
frere-jones they worked on knock out
together and Tobias is known for also
the much beloved Gotham typeface which
has been used on so many different
branding pieces from Saturday Night Live
to the Tribeca Film Festival last but
not least there's Erik Spiekermann who
designed Mehta awesome typeface now
looking into design firms world-renowned
that have used custom typefaces I could
think of none better than Michael Beirut
and pentagram this packaging that he did
and he presented this on stage for nuts
calm I thought was really cool it's
bright it's fun it's colorful it has a
very personal feel and he shared the
story about how he took out a brush and
started to draw a bunch of these word
marks nuts calm
then he turned these letter forms into a
typeface which allowed him to create
entire identity and branding package for
nuts calm and according to him after
they started doing this on very eco
friendly materials and adding some
personalization with these cute
characters sales skyrocketed not
convinced yet I have another example
from Michael Beirut for walk NYC and
here he was really looking for
inspiration from his design mentor
Massimo Vignelli and looked at the
subway station signage and these little
dots that are synonymous with New York
City subway so what he wanted to do is
take the classic cut of Helvetica and
change one aspect of it and refashion it
as a custom typeface for his client so
here's what he did he took the tittle
which is that squared dot above the eye
and changes into a circle these are the
clever little things that Michael likes
to do to make sure everything is custom
and bespoke for his client so that one
round dot is connected to what Massimo
McNally had done that's it
that one little dot now he renamed it
new Helvetica dot with three weights
regular medium and bold and used it
throughout the wayfinding system and he
also went so far as redesigning the
icon system to reflect the
characteristics of the typeface itself
the skirt of the are matches the leg of
the are the shoulder of the C matches
the roundness of the bus and so on and
so forth the thickness of the tires
matched the stem of the R now I
mentioned earlier there are a couple of
designers that I really look up to who
do quite well for themselves
selling fonts and Ian Barnard talks
about this that fonts have become his
primary source of revenue of passive
income and he has a bunch of typefaces
if you to go onto site and check it out
here are a couple and then there's a
good buddy dustin lee who you guys may
have recognized as one of the voices
behind our episode called passive income
business and dustin talks about a lot of
different things but for the sake of
this conversation i want to focus in on
fonts in particular so here are some of
the fonts that he offers as part of the
retro supply company this one really
caught my eye called block print which
is somebody literally cutting out a
linoleum block and printing this that
give it that super cool feel last but
not least their sam parrot who's used
font self to design a couple of
typefaces and he too is doing quite well
this one's called opulent it has a
really beautiful brushstroke look to it
one thing that you notice here is it has
transparency it has grayscale so now
with the use of new font technologies we
can include bitmap images as part of our
font not just vector and we can also
include color this is really cool look
how he's using this typeface so it's
called avalon OpenType and it's an SVG
font which allows you to use color and a
bunch of other tricks so there it is
there's my pitch to you if you're a
designer if you're interested in design
or even just having a bespoke element in
your design give font creation a shot
okay so you have no more excuses but to
get started now
alright this next segment I'm going to
talk about fundamentals that you need to
know just the basics so we have a shared
language with what good fonts look like
and the anatomy of typefaces so we'll
start off with terminology and Anatomy a
typeset this word typography and
I want to talk about some of the terms
first up is the baseline this is where
your characters sit on except for the
descenders and I'll explain what that
means in a second and at the very top is
the cap line for the capital letters and
it's hitting the cross bar of the tee
and that's it's on top of that and next
up is the x height and X height is named
after the letter X because typically
that letter ax has flat serifs on the
top and bottom where as you'll notice
the Oh overshoots the x height and the
baseline so that's why it's called X
height and lastly is the beard line
sometimes referred to as the descender
line and you think like why is it called
a beard line and I think it's because
typefaces of typeface and a lot of the
terms are based on human anatomy and you
think of the bottom of the face is the
beard and that's what that's sitting on
so that's where the the center of the P
is sitting on the beard line okay so now
I've colored all the parts that I want
to highlight and of course when you dig
deeper into this kind of stuff you'll
see conflicting terminology and what
people call things I did the best to my
ability to be able to call out things
based on cross-checking many things so
let's dive into it so first up from left
to right is the bar of the T and then
right next to that is the beak of the T
it's dipping down so it's called the
beak and then the vertical stroke is
called a stem the bottom of the Y it's
kind of like a cat so we'll call that a
tail it's wagging its tail and these
little things on the left and the right
of the letter P are called serifs and
serif is French I believe it means feet
so serif so with feet it has those
things on it this is called the counter
it's the closed part that's the white
area that's trapped the negative space
that's trapped inside the O on the top
of the lowercase G is called an ear that
the little thing that sticks out it kind
of looks like in the air or nose but
they call it an ear and this is a
two-story G and it has the top story in
the bottom story and the thing that
connects at the top and the bottom is
called the link and of course the bottom
is called the loop so there's
essentially two
oval shapes and what connects them is
called link and the bottom is called the
loop now if you look at the lowercase R
this is referred to as the bracketed
serif there's such a thing as unbranded
and bracketed serif and I'll talk about
what that means in the next slide so
here as we zoom him there's two
different typefaces here so one it Sun
bracketed where the serif has no
transition to the stem whereas the
bracketed Serra it transitions so
there's a curved drawing that connects
the serif to the stem next up is the
terminal it's the dot that finishes at
the top of a and then you have the belly
or the bowl of the a so it's a bowl and
that's what you're looking at and this
little thing on the right side some
typefaces have this part and some do not
so this is called a spur some letters do
you just finish straight up and down and
don't curve out like this it's called a
spur and you think about the spur of a
boot that's how you can remember that
the stroke that's that falls below the
baseline that's called the descender and
naturally the thing that falls above the
Exide is called the a sender and the
thing that connects this strokes on the
H this little part is called the
shoulder and that's what that is the
shoulder and that's it for type anatomy
and terminology I'm hoping that now with
a little bit more of understanding of
what these parts are called you'll start
to become more aware of them as you look
at other typefaces here's a quick recap
the review with all the terms up on one
page so if you want to you can screen
capture this and just save it for your
reference next thing I want to talk
about is called unity of design and is
this principle that makes typefaces what
they are all well design typefaces
display the principle of repetition and
variety so there are things that are
same and some things that are a little
bit different this was what makes it
feel like a family unless you're doing
that ransom note kind of typeface ok
letters can be clustered into four
groups according to the contrasting
property so here we go first letters
that have a strong vertical element like
the EF h IL NT next are letters that
have curb forms primarily the co the Q
and the s and they share lots of common
meets with each other and then we have
the ones that have a combination of
straight lines and curbed the best
example I could think of is the letter D
and the letter B as in baby and then
last but not least there's the obliques
the ones that have a diagonal line as
part of the character so here it is in
review the four different groupings the
clusters are vertical curved combination
and oblique now if we step in a little
bit closer we can also see that there
are commonalities between certain letter
forms and this is a really cool part
because once you draw one letter you can
reuse parts of that letter to generate
many other letters so if you draw the D
which is a combination a vertical and a
curved according to the clusters that we
just talked about you can see there that
the bowl the D the bowl of the D is
mirrored in the C the G the O and the Q
so it's not as hard as you think to
design a typeface if you just draw one
of these letter forms you can use parts
and pieces so if you're experienced
typeface designer you already know this
that you keep certain elements separate
so that you can cut and paste and move
them around okay I want to take a moment
also now to talk about something that
some people miss which is curved letter
forms overshoot the cap line and the
base line so when you draw the letter O
it's not supposed to sit inside those
two grid points it's supposed to
overshoot it goes above and below those
two lines next we see the diagonal
strokes of a B W and M also share a lot
of common parts if you look at the
letter A and the V the V is essentially
the same as a but just turned upside
down and it's missing the bar the
crossbar again the W has shared elements
with the V as does the M okay here the F
the E and the B in February also share
common components as you can see here
the B R K and P share common elements as
does the ATF and are in the lowercase
version of this typeface okay enough of
me talking it's time for us to go and
make something so here's my plan and if
you're paying attention you can tell
this is an SVG font because actually has
color inside I'm gonna do three
different types
three different fonts for you one I'm
gonna do a hand-drawn one which I'm
gonna do in the studio in just a second
I'm gonna take an existing typeface i'm
gonna modify and save it so that i can
have my own custom version of a typeface
and i'm gonna convert an existing
drawing into a usable font meaning there
are vector elements already so i'm not
gonna do this from scratch it's gonna
take a very long time and i'm gonna show
you how easy it is to convert an
existing vector drawing into a font that
you can use that's it so let's go and
drop i'll see you guys back in a little
bit so hang in there all right it's
another day that's another opportunity
to make some typefaces so i brought
along with me two markers a one has a
chiseled edge and one has a blunt point
and I think this could actually create
something of an interesting look because
it's gonna be inconsistent it could be
streaky and I want to have some fun with
this and I encourage you to do the same
so I'm gonna start off by drawing just a
few letters I've never done this before
so let's see how this works out let's
see what kinds of things I'm gonna learn
in the process I'm just gonna draw the
alphabet right and I'm gonna draw a few
letters to give myself some options
later on that looks pretty good
B
I'm just gonna do all caps some letters
are not as interesting to me
I just spent too much time drawing goes
once I'm done with this I'm gonna have
Jonah photograph this I res and I'm
going to convert them into artwork I can
auto trace or I can keep it
bitmapped so it has some of the
variations as you'll see cuz the ink
does not dry smoothly they the GMO I'm
struggling with here back to vertical
letters simpler so I'm writing this kind
of like the way I normally do my
whiteboard sessions so we will have a
very usable font that is custom totally
unique to base based on my own
handwriting style which is really cool
because you could do the same and I have
to admit it's a little less
nerve-wracking to do this
I'm actually not writing anything and
thinking at the same time usually when
I'm doing the whiteboard sessions it's
hard to write and talk at the same time
and spell correctly and if you're
nervous about doing something like this
you could have some practice letters
about where I was
- what do you think do you think you can
do this that is neat
I don't think they want my father well
maybe they really will want your font
because it'll be very unique now one
thing that I'm not paying attention to
and sometimes this happens when you draw
an angle your letters start going uphill
or they start getting bigger on the
right side because of the distance
hopefully that's not having too much
there we go so that's one that I'm gonna
do some numerals right now so let me do
some numbers
you can even draw alternate characters
for example the one I might want to do
one like that I might want to do an
alternate to the 7 I think that for the
most part these are pretty good try to
do one more the inside of the six is
clear okay oh I forgot punctuation so
I'm going to do quote apostrophe period
exclamation let me do that again
colon semicolon what else am I missing
oh yeah what's your question I'm just
kidding mmm minus symbol plus symbol /
short underscore long underscore tilde
surprised even though that is all
slashes backslash
oh the divider okay I think for the most
part we have a pretty complete alphabet
and you guys now we're gonna take this
and I'm gonna jump into the computer and
I'll see you then
net I finished drawing my letter forms
in the whiteboard I'm going to jump on
to my Macintosh computer here and open
up the file in Photoshop which is what I
have right now thanks to Jonah I was
able to get a pretty straight flat
photograph of the letter forms but as
you can see here there's some lighting
changes here you can see that there's a
little bit of vignetting so the first
thing I'm going to do is I'm going to
adjust the levels and I can do that by
pulling up the levels and then making it
go whiter in the highlights but I
noticed I can't get rid of everything
around here so that's good enough for
what I'm trying to do right now so I'm
going to take the marquee tool select
this in preparation will hide this for a
second command shift I to invert the
selection and do the levels again this
time I can really push it far oops what
am I doing wrong here levels here remove
the black permit there we go okay so
that's pretty white
now I'm gonna invert that selection
again and then do another levels here
and see what I can do with this so I
want to make it darker and the mid-tones
and then make it wider elsewhere and I'm
gonna just keep adjusting this until it
looks right to me and that's pretty much
it now with this I'm already noticing
some problems and perhaps why it wasn't
a great idea to draw this on a
whiteboard after all so you can see if I
pull some rulers out I'll do that if I
pulled some rulers out you'll notice
that my letter forms aren't sitting on a
base line or on a cap line this is gonna
be problematic for me I could see also
relatively inconsistent letter forms if
I'm create a new layer here I'll show
you what I mean by draw a box here and
color that so then if i duplicate that
down
and snap some guides here let's do it to
the baseline here and pull the guide
down right here and then pull the cap
line here you can see that this a and
the B is much much bigger than the rest
of these letter forms it's gonna cause a
problem I can see that now and in
hindsight would have probably been
better off to draw a baseline and a cap
line even an x height line even though I
don't have any lowercase letters here
and then draw that this is why it
probably makes a lot of sense to be
drawing this on tissue paper
aka tracing paper that way you can draw
the lines underneath and then have a
clean piece of paper on top this is also
critical if there is an angle which
you're drawing the letter forms to keep
the angles consistent versus it rotating
around and not being a consistent angle
so whatever live and learn I'll have to
fix this inside of Adobe Illustrator
okay I'm gonna jump in Adobe Illustrator
right now and I've placed my scanned and
cleaned up text in here and like I said
I could spot some problems and I'm gonna
see already I have a lot of stuff to fix
in here but what I need to do is go and
do a live trace on this and I have mine
docked right here but if you don't know
where that is you go to window and you
go to image trace image trace and I'll
pop up a window and the window look just
like this now the default settings are
pretty much what I think I need which is
to do black and white and I'm gonna
click on preview here and it's gonna
warn me all the stuff and you're gonna
click OK because you know what I live
dangerously so let's say okay now we
zoom in here this is the preview and if
you were to slide the threshold it'll
give you more or less detail I feel like
this is pretty good if you want to get
really into it you can control the
number of paths the corner is the noise
etc and I'm pretty good with this so I'm
gonna go ahead and convert this now and
hit trace so it should be done and let's
go to preview it's not done yet so what
I have to do is go to
in betrays where are you image trace
it's right here under object I'm gonna
image trace I'm going to expand it up
there we go expand and that's pretty
much it because it's nice and clean to
begin with I don't have too many things
to fix now what I have to do is I have
to separate these because there's a
white layer black layer I don't
understand but if you ungroup command
shift G I can then delete this part of
it and now I'm left with the clean
letters now what I have to do is
establish a baseline and an X baseline x
height and cap line so I'm going to go
and draw that let's say that the letter
let's say the letter B this letter B
looks pretty good
let me start working with this okay so
I'm going to hit command or pull out
some rulers I'm a snap and baseline in
there and I'm also going to zoom in here
just to see that and I'm gonna drop in a
cap line and some are usually a little
bit above the middle but you know what
I'm gonna do Center I don't have any
lowercase letters to deal with right now
so I'm gonna draw a box like that fourth
dimension you want to go and turn off
snap to pixel that's gonna mess you up
so make sure you turn off snap to pixel
okay I can already tell because it was
creating some problems for me let me
grab this and let me fill it with some
color so you guys can clearly see what
I'm doing here but I'll bring it right
next to the bead that I think I wanted
to use you can see it's a little bit off
I'm gonna just snap it to the guide and
then drop another ruler right there so I
know that's the center and I also have
to establish a horizontal with a stroke
and I'm gonna look for something that I
think looks pretty good let's say the
letter I oh no this e let's say that
we're gonna use this e right here this e
looks pretty good so I'm gonna steal
this e for right now and I'll move these
other B's out of the way this is off
okay bring this e in here and lo and
behold it is I have a little extra
something here
what is going on there's some extra
stuff there's some extra stuff I didn't
get rid of this it's all there huh okay
we have some extra bits here I'm gonna
have to clean up
where are my guides I need to lock these
guides okay getting into this so delete
that bring a seat down here and I'm
gonna make sure this sits on the base
line right there move it right up log
all right there okay okay I got pretty
lucky with this cap line and base line
and that's the middle so what I want to
do is establish a vertical stroke width
and a horizontal stroke width so let's
say this one seems pretty to be pretty
consistent I'm gonna bring it up here
I'm gonna pull it out so you can see it
yeah that's about right and then I'm
gonna bring it down here feeling pretty
good about that and then I'm gonna do
one in the middle I'm grab a by the
center Anchor Point and hit that middle
line right there theoretically that's
the center and now I can snap some
guides here here here and right here
this part is pretty tedious but once we
get going it should be pretty quick the
last thing I want to do is take this and
rotate it now you guys should know this
if you're paying attention to the
programs that we the videos that we
produce the vertical stroke needs to be
thicker than the horizontal stroke so as
reference I'm delete these right now and
we know this is exactly the same so if I
bring it over here you'll see that it is
a little bit thicker so I'm gonna move
this over and I'm making a little bit
bigger than that okay let's say that
that's a stroke so I'm gonna leave these
off to the side so that we have those as
reference okay so the vertical stroke is
going to be thicker because it needs to
be for optical saying otherwise it don't
make it feel too thin okay so those are
there we're good to go now
I want to show
a couple of the things I need to do and
then we can get really going here a
couple of things I need to do is I need
to label this this guide baseline and
this one cap line for font self to
recognize it and that'll be significant
later so I'm gonna go into my layers and
twirl this thing down and figure out
where the heck that thing you have so
I'm gonna unlock the guides I'm gonna
select this one and let's see where is
it there it is it's right here okay this
is the one we want this one we want to
call this baseline okay and then turn
this one on this one will be called cap
line okay and that's it no I could turn
on everything else that's one critical
thing took me a little while to figure
that out but later on you'll see why
that matters okay so now what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to move everything off
of this area select all of this stuff
and move it off because I just oops I
need to lock that back up which is
command option semicolon on the Mac I
don't know what it is on the PC
apologize you guys that use pcs okay now
I can start assembling all letters that
I need so I'm gonna grab the B put it
here so you have some options this a
looks pretty good to me I'm gonna drop
it in I'm not gonna worry too much
whether they line up or not I just need
to get this thing going now this C has
kind of an unusual quirkiness to it that
it's not quite as symmetrical as this C
but I think that's okay because there's
no point in me making a typeface that
winds up being perfect so I can see that
I have problems cuz my letters are all
over the place I need to bring these
letters out of the way and see what else
is here I'll get rid of all that let me
do command Y to make sure okay
you always take these things back put
them right back here okay and I'm not
gonna make you guys watch that because
that is boring I'm gonna just do this
and then we'll jump forward when I have
all the characters lined up nice and
tight
a couple of quick notes a couple of
quick notes here okay you want letters
that finish sharp like a horizontal or a
sharp vertical to hit the cap line and
the base line or as you want things have
curves to overshoot like this one or
hear it you want it to overshoot the
base line so you see there's a little
bit of a gap difference there and we
want to do the same thing with the top
so I need to take this I need to bring
it up sort of overshoots now you'll see
I got all kinds of problems and I need
to fix this so I'm gonna use my direct
selection tool move things around and
now you'll find that it's a little bit
more difficult to manipulate letter
forms like this because there are too
many points let's switch back to my pen
tool get rid of that and then start
drawing this adjusting it so that it
still has the characteristic of the
original see that I was looking for but
doesn't have as many points the points
will kill you it makes it very difficult
to adjust the letter form alright so you
can see that this process is gonna take
some time now when it went to live trace
this thing image trace it I mean just
this here you can see that the points
here should really be connected like
they shouldn't be independent where you
can adjust both parts like this the easy
way to fix that is use your pen tool and
hold down option on the Mac and then
draw it out like this and then now you
see that two handles are connected as
they should be because you want this
curve to be nice and smooth in
transition down there okay and we have
extra points we just click on top of it
turns to minus sign and that you could
adjust everything else you'll see that
it's a lot easier to draw on control so
I wanted to make that note about the
overshoot on the top and the bottom I
can see too that some of my letters are
leaning left or right or whatever so I
want to go and fix that so I'm just
gonna rotate these a little bit to try
and get them kind of straight before I
make additional adjustments I can also
see that this really should come down
farther here so sometimes just tapping
on the keyboard will get me there okay I
got some problems I'll need to fix here
got nothing but problems on this alright
I move this up and another point to note
here is I'm gonna I'm gonna grab the red
here and you'll see something that the
bowl of the be the first-floor bowl
versus the second one its protrudes
beyond this edge and it's supposed to do
that otherwise it'll feel top-heavy like
it wants to fall over but I can see here
I got sharp points where I don't want
them I want to smooth them out a little
bit and throughout this process I'm
gonna have to make a lot of decisions
about how perfect I want this letter
form because at some point it'll start
to look a little too perfect and lose
some of its personality
but I also want to observe good
proportions and rules in drawing letter
forms so I don't want to create some
kind of bastardized version that just
looks terrible when you typeset
something okay all right now I can see
that this it's not really a serif but
it's like where I drew the B from how it
went past this
I want to retain that so I have to just
nudge this up to kind of like where it
needs to be and then I need to fix all
this stuff so I think I need to bring
this down it's gonna take me a little
while to fix all this stuff then smooth
this out a little bit maybe it doesn't
need this point yeah that's a little
easier to control you see how getting
rid of points allows you to do that now
what I want to do I'm going to get my
brush tool here make just a little bit
smaller
oops I'll make it smaller there we go
switch to color switch to color to be
something like red I just want to make
sure that one draw it feels like it's
connected stroke there so I can tell
right now that this is not feeling like
that because it feels like it went down
so easy way to fix that is just bring
this up so it creates the kind of
imaginary line across and I can tell
here this line is too low and it's going
too high so we want to just draw that
across like with our eye okay all right
and these little things these little
nubby things I kind of like now I wanted
to line up with that possibly here so
I'm gonna bring
/ like it's the end of that stroke and I
overshot that line a little bit okay
once we're done we'll create all the 26
characters for the alphabet and then
we'll do our numerals and get those all
nice and tidy so I'll jump forward to
that right now all right we're back
inside illustrator I realized my file
got a little bit messy so I cleaned up
every single thing and you can see with
a lot of tweaking I got this thing to
look pretty consistent I'm sure there's
still some little funny things here and
there but I realized in the last demo I
didn't do a good job of drawing the
baseline and the cap line for you and it
got a little confusing and I figured out
a better way to show you that so what
you do is create a new layer I'm gonna
zoom in here again and I'm gonna do the
eye because the eye has the nice
straight there for me to work with I'm
gonna San Abbott outline I want to make
sure again good snap to pixels off and
then I'm gonna bring this one up here so
that's pretty much what the computer
needs to see for the cap and baseline so
what I'm gonna do now is in here I
realized that I need to draw something
on this layer there once I have
something drawn I can then I'll twirl
this down and see the two guidelines so
by double clicking on this let me double
check to make sure that's a baseline it
is I'm gonna call this baseline cap line
and I'm gonna tell you something that
you need to do that's critical for this
to work cap line okay that's done now
what I can do is delete this oops
delete those two things and unlock the
guides which is command option semicolon
I'm gonna grab these two and I'm going
to duplicate them while holding down
option down here so let's say it lands
right there okay so now I have cap line
baseline and now I can select all of
these things actually I think I could
just grab this and move that red dot
down so now they all they all need to
exist on the same layer for font self to
recognize it so this is how you avoid
this which is too many layers for us
looking at come on move this up out of
the way I'm gonna click on a different
panel so I could there we go
will juice up a little bit so you can
see so you see there's too many pads in
there of course okay a couple of things
I want to tell you about and is that
each one of these letters needs to be
its own object it's really important
that if you had a lowercase I with like
a exclamation point like this that they
need to be grouped together and the
easiest way I know how to do that is
actually just use a pathfinder and unite
them and there's some options here if
you want to look at this the option that
you want to do is let's see here
Pathfinder options is you want to remove
redundant points you want to remove the
redundant points okay so it gives you a
nice clean thing now some of these
drawings have more points than you
normally would want but I'm gonna say
that it's okay and if it bothered you
all you have to do is go in here and use
the pen tool and click on that and click
on anything you want to get rid of yeah
there's a lot of extra points there okay
that's all you would need to do but I
think some of those weird things that
when you're drawing out trying to draw a
like a beautiful perfect font you'll
probably need to clean up and make it
super optimal but for the sake of this
demo I think it'll be okay okay now what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna do my old Oh
what happened to my guides I think I
accidentally deleted him I'm gonna do
get the guides back there we go
I see they're still stuck on this layer
so I need to grab these two and move
them down here alright don't need that
okay now I'm gonna lock the guides
command option semicolon will toggle
that I shouldn't be able to select it
now okay anyways what I like to do is
zoom out and hide the guides which is
command :
and just squint and see if there's some
inconsistencies or irregularities that
I'm still seeing and hmm it's not
perfect like I can tell this part of the
Oh is a little thick on the top I'm
gonna zoom in there I want to fix that
see so when you see it from far away for
whatever reason I'm able to see it a
little bit better
then when I'm zoomed in that whole
zoomin zoom-out thing okay
I think that's a little bit better now
this parts problematic for me that's
because there's not enough points here I
don't have three points for a circle and
it really needs four gives me just
enough control to be able to bring that
down a little bit okay that looks pretty
good this part looks a little thin here
right and there's there's no rule as to
how perfect or how clean you have to
make this it's entirely up to you
I say depending on your levels of anal
retentiveness
you may want to adjust that all right
let's pretend like this is perfect and
you can work on this for days months and
years if you want but for me and for
this demo I think I'm good with this and
now what you do is you're gonna go up to
window you go to extensions and you're
gonna launch font self right there this
is I'm running version 3.5 it's got some
new features to it that were just
released I think I'm gonna be excited
about what we're gonna do here so I'm
gonna click on the A to Z a couple
different ways you can do this you can
drag it in and then it'll tell you which
one do you want it to be a DZ characters
etc I'm not gonna do it that way I want
to just use this right here so I'm gonna
click this and it'll generate all the
uppercase letters it will respect the
baseline that I've created I can make
adjustments here and if I do this I'm
gonna type in with the classic sentence
every type sends a quick brown fox jumps
over a lazy doc if I hit period I
haven't defined the period yet so that's
some weird thing that's gonna recognize
okay and what do we see here I think for
the most part looks okay the t looks a
little low I don't know why or maybe
it's the H it looks a little high let's
push H down a little bit and I think it
would adjust this dynamically the e is
high push it down make sure it sits
remember curved letterforms need to
overshoot a little bit so I'm gonna use
to use my high right now
[Music]
here I'll create the numbers so again
I'm gonna do this and hit Europe it's
9:00 and I think we're good there
you make some adjustments again and I'm
gonna create the lowercase letters by
hitting this since I don't have
lowercase letters ok now that we have
that done we can hit save and the way
that you want to save it is you want to
hit the word or the button install this
is for illustrator use only basically it
creates a font and only Hillis trader
can recognize and I like that because
white board okay and we can select this
typeface in a little bit and we can open
it up in the Browse insulation folder
and remove it if we need to but that's
okay I'm gonna close that now I want to
try out the new smart kerning function
here so I'm gonna click on this button
hit smart it's gonna say okay go ahead
and hit smart space and Kern its gonna
do its best job and it looks really good
already out of the gate I can see that
there's still some problems I think this
is the old T it didn't adjust that so
I'm gonna type in the new T it looks
pretty good quick brown fox jumps over
the lazy designer okay now if we want to
go and make some other adjustments we
can go to advanced and look at these
kerning pairs and there's quite a lot of
them there let's type in the how does
that look that looks pretty good
Danu
it also looks pretty good darn okay so
it's it's a made all these adjustments
for us already so we don't have to do
any of this so I'm gonna go back home
and I'm gonna hit install so it'll save
it basically and when you're ready to
export this to be used with other
programs you're going to want to hit
save and it'll create an OTF file for
you and then you can save that anywhere
and use it within other programs but I
think I'm kind of done with this and
let's just double check I'm gonna use
this
let's say we have a new whiteboard
session about how to skip school or skip
the degree let's call that skip that
degree how to avoid living debt okay so
if I hit command T which will bring up
my type panel I'll type in whiteboard
and I've been working on this so I think
that's the one I need so I'm gonna scale
this up and now you can see it skipped a
degree now if you don't like the way
that the default kerning works you can
change that so the way that you do that
is you go over here and you increase the
line space or the letter spacing so I'm
gonna increase it by just a little bit
open it up a little bit and I'm gonna
decrease the line space by a little bit
and once I hit install it should update
and this should change hello there goes
okay so I can type oops copy this again
delete this there we go so I want to
make it even tighter than not that feels
really open to me you know maybe it's
like that skip the degree how to avoid
living in debt and that is how you
create a custom typeface
now the I want to create two more
typefaces and show you a little bit I'm
not gonna go through the painstaking
process of doing this all over again
yeah and up next okay there we go now I
have a custom font that nobody else has
and I think that's a pretty cool thing
so just to make sure I'm going to go
ahead and save this font now I'm gonna
call it white board V - let's call it
zero one I'm gonna save on the desktop
hit save and now you can open that up it
has basically you can jump in Photoshop
you can use it dude for do it with it
whenever you want okay that's it for
this part I'm gonna come back and I'm
gonna convert some other fonts I'm gonna
talk to you about how to do that and
we're gonna wrap this up okay so if
you're like me you're able to download
different typeface drawings and things
like
but then actually official fonts off the
stock photography sites and I have such
an example here called facet and you see
that facet is colored and it has a drop
shadow so it's got some things going on
it even has a stroke on the letter forms
and font self can handle all those
things and it's got no problems at all
and one of the things that I notice too
is like if you hit this hamburger menu
on the fun stuff menu and go down to
font template it'll generate this file
for you which shows you the complete
characters which you'll need to build to
have a complete and usable alphabet and
a typeface a font if you will and I also
notice here the naming convention here
at baseline descender x height cap
height ascender so I'm gonna use that
when I go to name my guide somebody
don't save on this I'm gonna go over
here which I've already got a file set
up here it's ready to go
and I've created a cap height and a
baseline you can see it right here cap
height and baseline right over here okay
so I also realized that it has to be
unlocked and be selected when you are
doing this for it to recognize it I
guess that makes sense okay so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna select all these
letters and I'm gonna go over here like
before and I'm going to hit a to Z and
it'll generate it and it should come in
perfectly where everything lines up what
we'll do is we'll check the s if the S
dips a little bit below the baseline
which I can't really see here but I
think that's gonna be what we need I'm
hit a to Z for the lowercase letters and
don't generate those and now I have both
upper and lowercase
there's no difference here on a font
that you draw you'll probably have upper
and lowercase to use
all right so now that that's done I can
use this typeface once I hit the word
the button install and we're gonna call
this facet I mean okay it's great
it's ready to go and now I'm gonna test
it and I'm gonna type in some words the
quick brown dog jumps are lazy designer
oh there's a problem here
oh I see I have my two letters inverted
here I didn't even see that you see the
M and then here closer in the wrong
order so I want to select this letter
with this space line and hit the letter
N and I want to do it for the caps and /
kicked in the lowercase it's gonna
replace it and I would also don't
replace it with the lowercase and hit
great glyph I should take care of it
replace and I'm gonna select the M with
the base line again chef M gray clip
replace porque su replace now I may
install I should update it there we go
it fixed it so now my spelling is okay
so the quick brown fox jumps over the
lazy designer and I want to make some
adjustments here I want to open up the
letter spacing a little bit because it's
such a condensed typeface let me type in
the same expression over here copy/paste
all right over here it looks really open
but over there it does not sure what's
going on I'll also want to decrease the
line spacing and then I'm going to hit
smart turning so smart space and kerning
so just all that stuff and I think we're
pretty good now so if I hit install it
should update this it'll take us
okay now it's making the letter-spacing
really tight for me it's done a pretty
good job but you can see here in the LNA
it's too tight
so I want to go back in here and open up
a letter spacing now and hit install and
see what happens okay I'm gonna do it a
little bit more install there we go
okay and you can play with this for as
much as you want again this is pretty
cool two three four five six seven eight
nine which has everything with zero and
exclamation question mark all the good
stuff it's all working okay
later on I want to make a semicolon and
a bunch of other things but that's
working so if I want to save this I want
to be able to hit save
I'm gonna call it facet and replace the
other one that's fine replace it well
good okay I have one more demo to show
you and why this is super helpful I'm
sure your your mind is racing with ideas
and possibilities I'm gonna rejoin you
in a second all right and for this last
example I'm going to take one of my
all-time favorite typefaces Petera and
those of you guys have been paying
attention to the channel know that
that's one of my favorite type bases in
fact it is the inspiration behind the
name the future so there we go all right
now you know okay anyways let's just say
like you're a big shot and you want to
be able to modify an existing typeface
well you can't currently edit existing
commercial typefaces but what you can do
is you can convert them to an outline
make modifications to them and then save
them out and kind of have your own
custom version that you can use I'm not
here to answer the legal question of
whether or not you can do this or not or
whether or not you can distribute it but
I'm gonna make the assumption that you
can for personal use and something I've
never been fond of are the quotes and
the apostrophes from fedora I just
they're not pretty to me and it's
sometimes hard to tell if they're going
forwards or backwards or anything like
that so in this case here I've borrowed
quote marks from a different typeface
and I'm going to
use them to replace these so I'm gonna
outline this typeface I'm gonna ungroup
this command shift G and select these
and delete them and move those in here
and I think they're gonna look better to
be the knees yeah this might be
sacrilegious for some of you and for
those of you guys I feel like I'm doing
some crazy thing here it'll be okay
well I'll survive right you're allowed
to do whatever you want and I'm not
hurting anybody just doing some stuff
with type so as soon as I use this
version of the quote marks with Keturah
people are gonna notice people who
really pay attention to type will notice
like hey you did something different
there and I'll never tell
there we go and you and I everybody else
watching this video will know the same
thing that we know okay the whole point
is to show you what's possible a lot of
times people get caught up with like
well I would never do that that's not
that's not proper you should never do
that well sure you don't have to but I
will I noticed this goes a little bit
above that someone just create a little
line there and bring this one into the
same alignment as that make it go a
little north of that cap line okay
so now I can build my typeface hopefully
I was able to type correctly jl p q r s
t u v w x y&z perfect i'm gonna create
something new get rid the old one so i'm
gonna do a new font not a new style and
i'm gonna select these letter forms and
i'm gonna drop them in just like we've
done before okay now we got that and i'm
going to do the lowercase letters again
it's exactly the same I'm just like
these ones here and do 0 to 9 generate
those those also work beautiful
beautiful I'm a happy boy right now I'm
gonna delete this word quote because I
don't need the word quote or don't and M
I just need the glyphs that come with it
tell me okay so I'm just like this okay
now that's done I'm going to hit install
I'll call it ffv Torah for the future
for Torah there we go
okay now all I need to do is to use the
type tool and let's give it a try
that's lets use a quote and hello world
let's scale this up so you guys can see
us this is our typeface now let's Gotham
I'm sorry let's pull up good Torah and
there it is
well there we go
how cool is that now we need to fix the
kerning here because of Kearney looks
terrible and I'm gonna go in here and do
the smart kerning and like letter H I
don't know what that means I'm gonna
sconce smart Curnutt okay hit install
it'll update and save this thing and
hopefully everything will look a little
bit better look at that and I just
solved that is that cool Wow okay so
just like that we can have a custom
typeface and that's it for this I'm
super excited to see what you guys are
going to come up with and we're gonna
review those alright as I mentioned to
you guys before this video is sponsored
by font self and its easiest way to make
your own fonts they have excellent
tutorials on their site in both video
and blog style format so I would highly
recommend you guys check it out and here
are some of the things that make it so
cool you can convert any shape into a
character you can drag and drop fonts in
seconds and you can create both OTF and
SVG type fonts it runs both a Mac and PC
and it has new intelligent kerning tools
which I can't wait to share with you you
can even create custom ligatures and
alternate characters especially if
you're working
and the language like Spanish where you
need alternate characters and like I
said you can create color fonts now
which I'm gonna show you in a little bit
there are two versions that you can buy
and the really cool thing is there's no
new tools for you to learn except for
the plug-in and it's designed in a super
simple way so if you want the Adobe
Illustrator version it's $49 if you want
it both for AI and Photoshop for the
raster based bitmap images once you can
use this and it's a combo so it's 79
bucks I also want to showcase some
really cool typefaces that other people
have designed
now since founding this company in 2015
it was kick-started there have been now
over 300,000 custom fonts made by users
Wow I guess their mission to make
typeface creation and font design easy
is coming to fruition check out some of
these fonts wow that's cool right that's
neat
oh man this one's so cool look at this
one here we are now that you see me do
it and see how easy it is to do not only
is it easy it looks like a lot of fun
once I got started I can't stop so
here's the challenge for you design your
own custom font you could do any one of
the ones that I talked about or do one
on your own but here's the thing if
you're stuck for an idea just do your
own handwriting draw a couple of
characters with a sharpie make it super
easy scan it in convert it to vector and
play around with this font creation tool
you're gonna get hooked that's it if you
liked this episode you want to see more
content like this don't forget to Like
comment and subscribe and hit that Bell
notification and see you next time